13300 جديد من هيونغ يانغ بجوار العاصمة
تقدم البرق في بناء دفتر الصور
فين ، ليس لدي الواقع وأعود وأسلوبي
التعليق على الأرز ، وتمكين تنمية الحضارة
استخدم اسم الغليون للتبشير
يا أرز مريض
مرة واحدة
ero o ero
آه آه آه
[موسيقى]
[صفق]
94 قمت ببعض الأعمال المنزلية مع الشخص الآخر
شخص هههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههههه
السبابة
أنا أيضا
[صفق]
[موسيقى]
ولد الرفيق كيم جونغ أون اليوم وهو جديد
بازار الشجاعة يفيض بالتفاني
تقديس الروح ، بوابة ديناميكية لكلينا
عشرة آلاف جيل من الأرض غنية
الشيء 1 1 RBI كالغرفة الثامنة
بناءً على المخطط الثاني لمفصل دايجون جيونج
مراجعة بيئة الأرض
أوه نعم أسطورة
بعبارة أخرى ، يتمتع Hunter 4 بضحك كبير 2
[صفق]
لأنها مثل عاصفة ، أووو وغيرها
عجلة
أوه أوه
أوو
أوه ، موظف كان يعاني من زيادة الوزن ووجد إبراء ذمته بشكل عام
محكمة تفجير تعلن عن جونج القمامة
اعتقدت أنها كانت مريرة وليست مكروهة
[صفق]
احصل على الشر
خارج الى
آخر
كفاح إيفان سيرل
باطن القدم
لم يفعل
[موسيقى]
[صفق]